uh all right joining us now with more
reaction to Biden's speech and the
looming ground Invasion seemingly
imminent is 2024 presidential candidate
uh South Carolina Senator the good
senator from South Carolina Tim Scott is
with
us ly Lindsay likes to think that he's
the senior senator is that are you going
to let him get away with that listen
only for today the fact of the matter is
I'm running the president of the United
States so Lindy can be the senior
senator I almost said citizen senior
senator for South Carolina without any
question oh boy that's going viral in
South Carolina right now um look um and
thanks for coming in I know you've been
in New York the last couple days it's
great to have you in studio um this is
getting serious all indications are and
every Source I have on the ground is
saying it's imminent yes now there's
been an increase in activity in the
north with Hezbollah in Lebanon uh I
would imagine that any ground Invasion
would result in ratcheting up in the
north also now we're talking about the
potential of a serious two front War yes
that's that's a challenge for anybody
absolutely one of the things that we
need from this President is Clarity he
doesn't seem to be able to speak clearly
he gave a speech tonight remember our
Ally Israel was bombed by a terrorist
organization and tonight's speech
focused more on Ukraine than it did on
Israel that's unbelievable number one
number two if we're going to send the
kind of message that has strengthen it
we need the Gerald R Ford and the six
Fleet prepared in the Mediterranean as a
deterrent telling
Iran consequences are coming if you bomb
Israel and second I got a tough question
y y okay with with the words of Joe
Biden Joe Biden would they take it
seriously would he back it up would he
mean it I'm not sure he would well John
unfortunately you are smart you rais a
really good point number one look at his
past actions I always say as a guy who
spent time in financial services what
you did in the past can indicate what
you'll do in the future the Afghanistan
withdrawal devastating number one number
two telling Putin don't attack these
areas from a cyber warfare number three
a small incursion might be okay number
four let's get the Russians to work with
the Iranians on a new deal on our behalf
and number five the first message he
sent after the conflict started October
the 7th was a tell
Israel to stand down I think your point
is solid as a rock the weakness of this
president has caused chaos and conflict
around the world so we need a new
commander-in-chief so that what we say
we mean and that means there are
consequences that follow if we are not
loyal to our
allies No One Believes we'll be lethal
to our adversaries okay can how do you
explain the Obama Biden Administration
and the billions they gave Iran yes and
now explained Joe Biden wanting to give
$6 billion doll to Iran now that is
after he lifted sanctions and allowed
the Iranians now to sell all their oil
and because we artificially reduced our
output well that reduced the world
Supply that increased prices
dramatically everybody in the studio is
stealing it right okay so they they got
rich which ferments more terror gives
them more money for Terror then they're
getting six billion the thing from the
US right we know that fungible the word
everybody uses okay so you know based on
their action what is it about them that
they do not seem to understand the evil
that is Iran they want they have said it
they say it over and over again I would
start believing it that they want to
wipe Israel off the map death to Israel
death to America I believe they believe
that with all their heart and they think
they'd be doing God's will if they did
it period the only thing I'd add to that
is they don't want to just eliminate
Israel homas 's objective is to
eliminate every single Jewish person on
Earth and then attack Western democracy
there's a little Satan called Israel and
there's a big Satan called America any
president of the United States who
doesn't understand that cannot walk and
you gum at the same time and that is in
my opinion an abdication of
responsibility not to send a forceful
clear message with consquences to Iran
who funnels money to Hamas and Hezbollah
and to push back in the Bank against the
Palestinian Authority who canel their
meeting because they were able to
disrespect the president of the United
States interpret what what is their
rationale what is their thinking is it
that well if we be really nice to Iran
and if we show them kindness they
they're going to be kind back um people
that say they want to wipe you off the
face of the earth I don't think are very
kind people believe them believe them
here all I can tell you is that the
Reagan Doctrine of peace through
strength worked decade after decade
after decade weak liberal radical
leadership from the farle who's more
interested in appeasing the squad and
anti-semites in their party than they
are standing up for the right thing call
the Hamas caucus oo you know well
they're certainly a part of the
propaganda machine coming out of Hamas
in spite of all the evidence that showed
that in fact it was not Israel that was
responsible for the hospital bombing
that they say killed 500 first of all
the hospital barely got any damage it
was in the parking lot there's no way
500 people died and you know how do you
react the media every single major media
organization in this country and around
the world BBC French Press every
American Network that I can mention New
York Times Washington Post ABC NBC CBS
msdnc fake news CNN evil terrorists are
believed over the state of Israel how is
that why wouldn't they check their
sources listen whether there was the ap
of the New York Times I said it
yesterday I'll say it again and we'll
have to say it tomorrow as well check
your facts because at the end of the day
the false propaganda caused
consternation and the mobilization of
Hezbollah it saw Iran say they're going
to start having consequences based on a
lie yeah by the way are you missing home
I mean don't you hate New York well you
know by way I am leaving tomorrow
morning so the answer is I was the road
Tim and don't come back no more if you
work a single day in New York they tax
you for the day you know that right so
you're going to be taxed for these two
days you've been here I'm just saying
well I thought it was 12 hours but two
days who can tell who who if you're here
one minute they tax you it's
unbelievable yeah welcome move to South
Carolina getting out do your show remote
from South Carolina reduce your taxes
bring your audience with you we'll have
a great old
time got lucky yeah great to see us
appreciate
uh thank you all right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else